jamal walker is a normal guy working a
full-time job at a theme park called
medieval world the owner of the park is
worried about its future because it is
suffering financially in addition a
competitor theme park called the castle
world is opening right next to them if
they do not come up with new ideas the
medieval world is bound to go bankrupt
one afternoon jamal is tasked to clean
the ditch surrounding the park while he
is at it he notices a medallion in the
water which looks like it could be worth
a lot of money probably 35 from the gift
shop while trying to retrieve it jamal
falls into the ditch and although it is
pretty shallow he drowns when he comes
out of the water he sees that he is no
longer in the park he rationalizes that
this must be in castle world which is
near to their park what jamal doesn't
know is that he has been sucked into the
past into 1300s england the first person
he meets is a drunkard named nolte
although he is clearly wearing ancient
clothes jamal thinks he is a worker in
costume ignoring the man he makes his
way into the city and comes across a
massive castle which to him is the main
attraction of castle world he tries to
go inside but is stopped by the guards
they ask him where he is from to which
he replies normandy jamal means normandy
from la but the guards assume that he is
a french moor who they had been
expecting to come next week they let him
in and jamal is introduced to a bustling
market where everyone is wearing
clothing from the 1300s he's impressed
by the accuracy of the theme park still
unaware that he has traveled through
time suddenly his eyes land on a
beautiful girl named victoria jamal
approaches her to shoot his shot but
they are interrupted by the cruel
commander general percival he acts like
he owns all the women in the town just
because he is a royal guard hence his
ego is hurt when he gets a bit too close
to victoria and jamal stops him he
threatens to complain to the manager
about the misconduct percival pulls out
his sword on him but jamal thinks it is
fake and surprises everyone with his
bravery following that he meets a
stranger who brings him to the king at
his request the king has arranged a
marriage between his daughter regina and
the duke of normandy he thinks jamal is
a messenger and inquires when the duke
is going to be here a confused jamal
plays along and randomly names a date
later that day he is taken outside to
witness an execution he is excited
thinking that they are just actors
playing along with the theme the
execution goes smoothly but when jamal
picks up the decapitated head of a rebel
his world
changes he is so in shock that he falls
unconscious without saying a word when
jamal wakes up he finds himself in his
room with victoria he is wearing the
medallion that he found in the ditch
which makes her believe he is one of her
people she shows him her medallion which
is similar to his turns out the
medallion is a symbol of the rebellions
who are tired of the king's cruel
judgment system he has dethroned the
former queen unfairly and has killed
many innocents for criticizing his rule
the group of rebels want to kick him out
of the kingdom and bring the former
queen back into power still confused
jamal asks her what date it is and finds
out it is
1328 a.d he freaks out and wants to
return to his own time but doesn't know
how they are then interrupted by a guard
who invites them for a horse riding
adventure because of jamal's lack of
knowledge about horses he amuses
everyone with his horse riding technique
even the king enjoys the show and then
invites him to a royal dinner that night
the party is dull so jamal lights it up
by dancing like he used to in the future
everyone joins him and it becomes the
most lively party the palace has ever
held in the middle of it princess regina
pulls jamal aside and forcefully plants
a kiss on his lips she has been hitting
on him ever since his arrival but was
too scared to approach him in front of
her father percival catches him
red-handed and is enraged by the
audacity of the newcomer at the same
time two rebels are seconds away from
attacking the king jamal hangs by the
chandelier and lands on the king
ironically saving him from the rebels
when the situation calms down percival
is reprimanded for not doing his job
properly while jamal is praised and made
the head of security percival drowns in
jealousy and anger but he's bound to
keep his head down in front of the
king's decision being the head of
security jamal is given a bunch of
responsibilities he puts forward his
idea to rebuild the opening to the
castle with his head which he argues
will keep the enemies away before the
plan is implemented the king calls him
for a more important task a farmer was
found stealing a turnip from the royal
garden even though it was to feed his
starving family he is ordered to be
executed for his crime moreover since
jamal is the security head he is the one
that has to take care of the execution
when the king leaves he lets the poor
farmer go and even gives him some money
for food at night jamal asks to be
presented with the finest chambermaid
for his entertainment he chooses
victoria and gets her alone in his room
with the excuse of sleeping with her
victoria still wants him to be an asset
to the rebel group and help them
assassinate the king however after
seeing that the king kills people over
vegetables jamal is no longer interested
in rebelling victoria is disappointed
but he argues that he is just not the
man for the job she calls him a coward
and leaves at midnight a woman comes
into jamal's room and makes love to him
he thinks it is victoria and doesn't
protest the next morning the real
messenger from normandy arrives and the
king finds out jamal has been lying to
them he the messenger and the guards
barge into jamal's room and find him
naked with princess regina by his side
percival accuses him of forcefully
deflowering the princess jamal argues
that someone had already got to the
princess's flower before him but no one
listens the messenger calls off the
wedding because regina is no longer fit
to be a duchess as a result of the chaos
jamal is thrown into the dungeon and
arraigned for execution with the two
rebels who attempted to assassinate the
king in the dungeon jamal makes friends
with the rebels who have already
accepted their death they tell him the
story of the black knight a
revolutionary warrior it is believed
that the knight could not be bribed with
all the money in the world and would
fight vigorously for justice in one of
the battles he was swallowed whole by a
dragon however with the help of a sword
of gold he cut himself from the belly
and killed the beast after the incident
he could even breathe fire like a dragon
itself the next day the trio is brought
in front of the crowd to be executed in
a moment of panic jamal tells people
that he is a wizard from the future who
has the power to burn everyone he tries
to prove his point by using a lighter
but it doesn't work when he is seconds
away from being beheaded the executioner
begins to choke on an apple this makes
the crowd believe he has cast a spell of
death upon him jamal goes with the
misconception and pretends to do the
same on the crowd suddenly a fire breaks
nearby proving his power to the
commoners but in reality the rebels are
firing flaming arrows from outside the
castle to save their people in the end
jamal and the others escape the castle
with victoria's help jamal also meets
the drunkard named nolte on horseback
and finds out he used to be the knight
of the former queen he was one of the
greatest warriors of the kingdom before
the king dethroned the queen and kicked
him out as well he eventually turned
into an alcoholic but somewhere inside
everyone knows that the fighter in him
is still alive after spending some time
with the rebellious group jamal realizes
the severity of the situation and
decides to help them dethrone the king
at last while in the woods he notices
three men troubling nolte for no reason
he helps the guy but is caught by the
thugs himself nolte comes out of his
shell and fights the bullies to free
jamal he is now motivated to quit
drinking and help the group in their
purpose the two then return to the
settlement and find it in shambles it
turns out percival and his troops have
destroyed it and abducted victoria
everyone loses hope of ever winning this
fight when the former queen reveals
herself she discloses she was with them
all this time helping them from the
shadows for the next few days the group
prepares to plan a better attack jamal
who has the knowledge of the future
teaches them tactics used in american
football and pro wrestling this gives
the unarmed rebels a means to battle
when the time comes he himself learns
some basic sword fighting techniques
from nolte then the day of the attack
finally comes the group prepares itself
and gets ready to fight with their lives
nolte leads them to the castle but in
only a few minutes they are completely
surrounded by guards under percival's
order they are outnumbered and pushed
back then to everyone's surprise the
battlefield is invaded by the black
knight himself he makes a grand entrance
urging the guards to run away from him
not only that but he also breathes fire
out of his mouth the rebels finally
think they are about to win but that is
until the black knight falls off his
horse revealing that he is none other
than jamal himself percival is about to
end his life when nolte comes to his
rescue and fights the guard following
that a fierce battle ensues between the
two parties using the techniques that
jamal taught them the commoners are able
to trick and defeat many guards amidst
the battle the king runs to percival and
begs him to bring him to safety percival
sees him as a weak and unworthy leader
hence when the king tries to give him an
order he in turn orders him to shut up
and pushes him off the castle into the
mode the fight seems to be shifting to
the side of the rebels until percival
shoots a longbow at nolte and hurts him
gravely after that he takes victoria
hostage jamal bolts to her rescue and
uses the technique taught by nolte to
fight percival is surprised and tries
his best to stay his ground but in the
end jamal wins and manages to rescue
victoria as he is picking her up
percival stands up again getting ready
to kill jamal once and for all however
he is shot dead by nolte who is still
alive on the battlefield in the end the
rebels become the victors and jamal
turns into everyone's hero a few weeks
later it is time for him to return home
he wishes victoria goodbye and leaves
her with one last kiss before departing
the queen awards him as the black knight
of the kingdom flattering
racist but flattering a while later
jamal wakes back up in the 2000s
surrounded by a paramedic and his
colleagues from the theme park they
disclosed that he drowned in the ditch
and was saved but has been unconscious
ever since the rational way to describe
his experience would be to call it a
dream but jamal knows it wasn't that
before he went into the past he wanted
to leave his job to transfer to the
castle themed park where he could make
more money but now his attitude has
changed because he knows almost
everything about the medieval world he
offers his ideas to the owner and makes
the theme park more on theme that's the
corporate attitude jamal it becomes a
huge success that overshadows the castle
world's opening six weeks later jamal is
taking a stroll in the park when he
comes across a woman named nicole who
looks exactly like victoria nicole
comments that he looks familiar and the
two start a conversation they feel the
sparks between them but nicole has to
leave because of her nephew suddenly
jamal remembers to ask for her number
and runs behind her but while trying to
catch up he falls into the ditch again
this time he wakes up in the coliseum of
ancient rome about to be devoured by
lions unfortunately this movie got
slammed by critics and it never got a
sequel so
jamal probably died subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching